there is alex cobb you see the four
starts on a year how about that era 2.75
19 and two thirds only 13 hits travis
shaw at the plate
fly ball left field fairly deep
palleka back near the track and makes
the catch so a quick six pitch inning
it's gonna be a real test for hanjin ryu
tonight he's making his fifth start he's
one and one ena just over four pedro
severino who's cleaning up rudder at
second 2-2 another weak ground ball
struck to the shortstop joe panick's
playing there tonight throw on to first
in time to get severino and retire the
orioles
rowdy teles at the plate ground ball
left side what a play velazquez up and
throws him out you can plug a guy in
like this that can make those types of
plays and that is so big for a pitcher
and for a defense to have a short stop
and strong in the middle so there are
blue jays at second and third now with
one away in the third inning orioles put
a big shift on for biggio swung on a
weak little grounder up the third
baseline cobb flips it home not in time
gorielle with a head first slide to beat
it
and the blue jays take a one nothing
lead gritchik stands in runners on the
corners and one out there's a swing and
a fly ball hit the deep center field
back goes mullins at the wall it's gone
the two spot agrees with randall grichik
as he belts his third home run of the
season it's a three run shot and the
blue jays are up four nothing enzanton
dare standing at second with one away
pedro severino stands in
hit hard into the gap
santander gets the green light around
third he'll score and
put down another rbi for pedro severino
number 19 on the year
vizio grichik and shaw in this inning
against alex kub
sir sir
bring them up that's that old front door
fastball here's grichik and the 1-0 is
pounded on the ground to third ruiz
charges in picks funny hops as he throws
to first and bridgette going nobody on
this is travis shaw one for two
and he got him looking
he got him looking
getting ready to take his shin guard off
not gonna happen alex cobb will pitch
into the sixth once again to oscar
hernandez
looped and it's caught by a diving
velazquez the shortstop it started to
hook on velazquez and then he got great
extension moving towards his right and
he takes a hit away from hernandez i'll
tell you one thing velasquez is putting
on a glove show tonight i got some stars
on my scorecard and they got sixes next
to him he's been pretty sharp tonight
just a couple over in the middle ponzer
alberto rio deals swank and a miss chase
a high fastball he's met his match
tonight engine ryu has held him hitless
two balls and two strikes on anthony
santander
here's a ground ball that should be two
it's picked up by panic goes division
for one the pivot on to first in time a
double play to retire the orioles here
in the sixth inning so first and second
here's randall grichik hit a three-run
homer runners lead from first and second
1-0 pitch is a little fister into
shallow right dropping quickly and it
will fall in front of santander base hit
alberto picks it up and in the score is
jansen to third goes biggio a bloop
single scores a run by randall grichik
and the blue jays extend their lead to
five to one a four ribby night for the
blue jays center fielder ball two
strikes to nunez
one two pitch is hit on the ground to
third diving stop by shaw from his knees
throw across the diamond and just not in
time watch this ball just melted down
the line lays out
just gets to both knees and throws it
across the diamond with something on its
short hop and
i was going to say they're going to
review that play it was very close
and it is overturned
nunez is out terrific play on both ends
by shaw and teles as it turns out
blue chase in front five to one batting
in the ninth kevin begiot that's hit in
the air out towards left field starting
to travel smith getting to the wall he
leaps in the air and it is gone
kevin beggio with an opposite field two
run home run in the ninth and the blue
jays blow it open late seven to one
toronto
third hit of the night for kevin biggio
his sixth home run of the season
back at camden yards and cranking again
for kevin biggio
last season he hit five home runs
against the orioles
and his first beat against baltimore he
goes long again 3-1 pitch to nunez
mullins out at second
popped up
this should do it wait and see no it
falls in mullens will score
and nunez gets an rbi good for him
mullins comes around and orioles still
breathing
pedro severino digs in he's one for
three with an rbi severino swings at a
line drive caught on one knee by panic
to finish the ball game and the toronto
blue jays go to baltimore and pick up a
seven to two win on the strength of
randall grichik's night a three-run home
run and an rbi base hit later on in the
ball game and the knockout blow courtesy
of cavan vigils ninth inning two run
shot